à l'astral part d'inconscience malte cet
album c'est un fossé en l'afld
on peut pourtant c'est un hindou
[Applaudissements]
l'opération étaient préparés avec
minutie
l'escouade des stupéfiants de la police
de québec s'apprête à arrêter un vendeur
de drogue de synthèse
[Musique]
merci qui les antécédents criminels
depuis plusieurs années connu de nos
services
les policiers ont saisi 800 $ en argent
comptant et seulement 40 de comprimés de
méthamphétamine la drogue de synthèse
qui la très populaire au monde
on apprend une grossesse où on
déstabilise le costume en rien ne lui en
fera peur dans des points de vente comme
sûre mais par contre faut penser à nos
amis soyez situation les autorités
n'arrivent pas à contenir l'explosion
des drogues de synthèse enquête sur ces
nouvelles substances chimiques
dangereuses qui passe les frontières
comme une lettre à la poste
nous avons remonté la filière de
montréal à shanghai
tous ces drogues sont produites en
quantité industrielle
le mx c'est vraiment du poison et se
produisent et sans danger sans danger
pourtant les drogues de synthèse en fait
plus de 60 morts au pays l'an dernier
d'habitude je garde jamais rien chez
nous mais je savais qu'on allait se voir
aujourd'hui fait que ça un kilo de mdm à
ckoi des tu aimes dmc de l'ecstasy peur
notre enquête commence chez un revendeur
de drogue de synthèse
j'en veux un 2 3 kg par semaine je serai
pas compris à toi les profils ouais
j'irai 25000 places par semaine 25000
dollars par semaine elle est que c'est
un trafiquant depuis 20 ans il nous dit
qu'il fait aujourd'hui plus d'argent
avec les drogues de synthèse qui n'en
faisait avec le cannabis les marges de
profit sont tellement élevé que c'est un
peu stupide demande hip hop des affaires
comme ça quand tu peux ventes de l'acsta
site fait trois-quatre fois dix fois ton
argent sur chaque vente
il s'approvisionne auprès d'étudiants
bio chimie qui fabrique des drogues de
synthèse n'est pas beaucoup de john key
bikers qui vont à l'université pour
apprendre la biochimie la plupart que
moi j'ai rencontré ces des étudiants
brillants qui veulent faire de l'argent
partout à montréal toronto québec à ce
pays rimouski chicoutimi shawinigan
nomme une ville y en a
chaque ville aurait donc son laboratoire
et ses nombreux vendeurs les drogues de
synthèse sont très accessibles
c'est vrai qu'on va là je peux pas dire
que non même même je le crie haut et
fort y en a c'est sûr
mejia il ya toutes sortes de drogues
kétamine cocaïne torchis ya aussi de la
cmd ya de tout ça talents de scène
[Musique]
mais pourquoi moi + 17 et de celle des
taux que de l'alcool je trop bons de
caisse
j'ai frôlé sentiment même dit que la
vierge collaboration
si ce seuil est de ne même plus ce
qu'est de la bière fait bien prennent
vie dans l'est mais c'est peu c'est fun
[Musique]
c'est ce que mon épée je trouvais ça
fait comme effet cadeaux tous les
ça donne envie d'en floués
[Musique]
alex n'est pas un petit vendeur local
ils achètent au québec mais il revend
partout sur la planète partout mais aux
états unis en angleterre toute l'europe
l'australie l'homme les je les ai vus
j'ai même trouvé des pays que jamais
même pas qui existait parce que le monde
me trouve et nous dit qu'il reçoit et
expédie des drogues par la poste sans
problème ça c'est des commandes que j'ai
oublié de poster qu'est ce que tu
attends âmes des morts de l'héroïne la
cocaïne cette année suffit peut-être ça
peut être pas mal n'importe quoi
je sais moi comment battre les douanes
j'ai des trucs
ça fait longtemps que je fais ça je sais
ce qui marche
je le sais ce qui marche pas mais je
veux pas parler de ça mais des façons de
faire
c'est certain qu'il ya des façons de
nous avons voulu vérifier s'il est si
facile de déjouer les douanes
canadiennes
nous contactons un important producteur
de drogues de synthèse en chine
il nous propose une centaine de drogues
chimiques
nous lui recommandons deux pays une
drogue qui imite la mescaline illégale
dans plusieurs pays européens
cette drogue est toujours légale au
canada et à briques en chinois prétend
qu'il n'a jamais de problème avec des
douanes canadiennes
[Musique]
centre de tri postal de montréal ce
convoyeur déverse 14 millions de colis
par année difficile de déceler ceux qui
contiennent de la drogue
[Musique]
les drogues de synthèse cache souvent
dans de petits paquets les agents ne
sont pas autorisés à ouvrir les envois
de moins de 30 g 100 g peut faire dans
un zeppelin plat dans une enveloppe
je ne l'a peut-être en france où nombre
d' enveloppe qui peut circuler dans le
monde tout moment dans une journée
si un possible intérêt
un patient de contrôler c'est impossible
de contrôler tout tout tout tout est
possible de tout contrôler une nouvelle
drogue entre au pays chaque semaine
des substances chimiques inconnus que
les autorités sont incapables de
détecter parce qu'ils auraient pas d
indice qui laisserait croire que c'est
un produit dit c'est que je peux même
pas prononcé mon panneau des baigneurs
et des odeurs mais encore là les
nouvelles molécules nos chiens ou les
tests avons testé sur quoi sont quelque
chose qui connaissent pas mais que sont
ces nouvelles drogues chimiques pour
comprendre
nous nous rendons laboratoire du
chercheur claude rouillard toutes les
drogues de synthèse tant l'art produit
des effets de drogue déjà connu en or
une panoplie assez assez grand nom peut
penser qu'au cours des dix dernières
années au moins 200 nouvelles drogues de
synthèse qui ont été synthétisées et la
majorité d'entre elles sont encore légal
200 nouvelles drogues de synthèse et le
potentiel d'en créer d'autres est
immense on parle de produits chimiques
et on a fait des molécules qui sont
puisque puisqu'au active donc il y aura
des effets sur le cerveau et on consomme
ces molécules d'eau quand on part d'un
molécule le droit d'un synthèse
on a une possibilité et non de faire de
nouvelles molécules et c'est pour ça
qu'on dit on un explosion quand même
assez importante des drogues de synthèse
de nos jours de cette explosion plus
d'un laboratoire clandestin de drogues
de synthèse est démantelée chaque
semaine au pays
malgré tout les policiers n'arrivent pas
à freiner la production
les laboratoires sont aménagés n'importe
où n'importe comment
on y mélange n'est porte quoi aller
vraiment compris mais c'est tout des
jaunes six pour la santé on pense être
les substances que tu peux y trouver les
faits d une façon ou lithium met à mal
et à mol la signoria ti-cats site leurs
idées selon le capitaine françois collin
de la police de québec les trafiquants
sont devenues des apprentis chimistes et
sans scrupules moi j'ai vu dans des
lourds dans un océan entre autres lors
c'est qu'ils achetaient des as et demi
au milieu en grande quantité dans les
magasins rayon puis broyés tout
simplement le aluminium dans une
déchiqueteuse à papier
pis c'est la substance laussou puis
éventuellement compris c'est directement
j'ai jamais vu un chimiste qui fait
n'importe quelle drogue de synthèse qui
se dit je veux être certain que ça c'est
c'est pour le client il veut juste être
certain que ça va se vendre que ça va
bosser en crise pilati on y est
également allé merci un moment donné de
de nairas dans la manipulation de ces
drogues l'aude le chimiste qui est un
chimiste que j'appelle dans mon langage
qui connaît le chimiste qui a pris sa
chimie à travers des articles sur
internet mais il risque un moment donné
qu'il chauffe trop il il va faire une
substance qui est différente et l'on ne
risque était pourtant c'est arrivé en
californie en 1982 un de ces petits
cônes chimistes comme les appelle claude
rouillard a réussi à synthétiser de
l'héroïne
la china white en l'espace de quelques
semaines plusieurs consommateurs sont
arrivés aux urgences avec les mêmes
symptômes tremblements et rigidité
musculaire mais l'on s'est aperçu que
ces gens là et est devenu du jour au
lendemain
parkinsoniens et en remontant l'histoire
s'est aperçu que ces gens là avaient
consommé dans les semaines précédant une
héroïne synthétique la maladie de
parkinson s'est déclarée du jour au
lendemain
chez ses consommateurs normalement pour
faire la recette on devait chauffée à
telles températures durant huit heures
de temps qu'est ce que la personne fait
tort raccourci la période où il devait
chauffer y augmenter la température rio
produits dérivés qu'on connaissait pas
le mptp un dérivé d'une drogue qui est
extrêmement dangereuse ce qui le détruit
par exemple des cellules nerveuses de
façon très spécifique dans le cerveau
ils l'ont échappé belle
cette fois là les médecins ont trouvé un
antidote mais encore aujourd'hui le
risque d'une mauvaise manipulation
est énorme les consommateurs de drogues
de synthèse n'ont aucun moyen de savoir
ce qu'ils achètent réellement les plus
extrêmes d'amener la commande sur savoir
est ce que c'est vraiment ce que tu sais
quand tu la prends on peut pas vraiment
savoir puisque nous l'avons fait à
chadrac exactement rêve c'est vraiment
cave passé le cut ce chapitre c'est
parce que mes 6 et d'une connaissance
c'est une écuelle à une roulette russe à
différents points de vue par exemple si
j'agis je dois dire par exemple space je
ne sais pas quel est l'ingrédient actif
la date ça peut normalement ça devrait
être des cannabinoïdes synthétiques mais
je ne sais pas quel cannabinoïdes
synthétiques
je ne sais pas en quel con sans pression
et même la personne qui le synthétiser
ne sais pas non plus ça pouvait aller à
un niveau insuffisant produire l'effet à
un niveau suffisant produire une
overdose
[Musique]
xavier cossette l'a appris à ses dépens
dans un club il faut que j'avais encore
l'écart à 2-1 puis acheté le jeu sous
jeter leurs rangs beaucoup sous qui le
touche mais je me répète vente du ghb de
rue c'était une bouteille de plastique
mais y'en a ras bord et ça le fait que
j'ai comme tout butin d'un coup puis je
tombe à tamar est en arrêt cardiaque
les médecins lui apprennent ce qu'il a
consommé ce soir là dans l'avalanche de
18 c'est là qu'ils m'ont dit on à prix
réduits de richie s'est fait cuisiner
des affaires comme ce 22 décembre 2011
shaver mais comme ac est en détresse son
ami appel le 9 avr
[Musique]
elles étaient quatre des amis de
secondaire 5 des premières de classe qui
consommait à l'occasion d'un sommet
commun qui arrivent à l'hôpital
sa fréquence cardiaque et 297 battement
minutes
c'est trois fois plus que la normale
après trois jours aux soins intensifs
j'aime en sept ans
[Musique]
en colombie-britannique et en alberta
dix-sept jeunes sont morts en un an et
demi tous croyaient avoir consommé de
l'ecstasy
le mdm a mêlé chimiste avait remplacé le
mdm à part du pnm à une substance
semblable mais beaucoup plus forte
le ndm vont rentrer en action entre 15
et 20 minutes après qu'on a ingéré
lattes la pilule la table
le pm et moi peut prendre jusqu'à une
heure une heure et un peu plus qu dans
donc les utilisateurs
prenez une pilule après 20 minutes
quatre armes ignobles n'y a pas d'effet
en prennent un autre cas prenez une aute
en prenez un autre [ __ ] coup c'était
lié au niveau de vos dos puissant mât
puis sont décédées
les drogues de synthèse sont présentes
aussi dans les écoles secondaires du
québec 17 % des élèves de secondaire 5
disait en avoir consommé l'an dernier
c'est un élève sur six
des chiffres qui n'étonne pas la docteur
marième morin quand on voit dans les
écoles quand je pose des questions et on
les réponses à toutes neuves la main et
autour déjà vu sur un spin je redemande
peau avez-vous déjà pris du pays de
jeudi le veinard et ceux qui ont déjà vu
un super d'élèves tout ça oui toi car la
main pour une drogue qui est plus
puissante que la cocaïne qui se vend
moins cher
je trouve ça très préoccupant à québec
les policiers ont fait 356 saisie de
drogue dans les écoles secondaires l'an
dernier le tiers des stupéfiants saisis
étaient des drogues de synthèse discours
entre aux dissidents et étudiants qui
étaient pris en possession de
méthamphétamines d'utiliser l'eau pots
de pilules puis à l'intérieur insulet
des méthamphétamines fait qu inquiétant
en arrière en classe puis tu prends
comprimé comme ça ça peut laisser croire
que ce que le pr mandats parité alors
qu'ils se calment est infinie
car l'interception c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'air de prendre de drogue
on a l'air de prendre exemple un
médicament puis qui nous donne un effet
mix certains d'impulsion fait qu'on n'a
pas l'air de tricher ou de contourner m
c'est ça le problème cdp le de couleurs
qui cote maximum saint-pierre chaque ça
donne pas les yeux rouges ça sympa ça
coûte pas cher ça coûte moins cher
qu'une botte at on pense alors inspiré
coûte moins cher qu'un gramme de potes
c'est facile à trouver
c'est moins facile de se faire prendre
puis pour eux c'est récréatif navy a
consommé du speed quotidiennement
pendant des mois
c'est en prenant le plein plein plein
plein plein de gars comme toi qui compte
c'est pas une psychose métier comme tu
penses pas comme tu penserais
normalement qui le situe entre 6 et un
christ comme d'abord la presse est
arrivé chez moi puis le c'est là que
j'ai pris 3,4 chose que chapeau 10 to
stay quoi y est arrivé en bout ici à
pouliot pris un couteau mais grande
foule
alors moi je me suis mis 20 j'ai dit je
me donne tout racheter enragé mais
contre y jetait dégressivité magazine
heat et toutes les émotions à l'envers
comme la clé donc j'avais mais c'était
vraiment christ je vous laisse je
voulais tuer quelqu'un
johanne gagné réussi à amener son fils à
l'hôpital davier et isolés dans l'es4 et
m'ont pris pour un tel zèle de force on
pouvait pas le voir j'ai pu le voir dix
minutes l'élan mais seulement quelques
jours de temps c'était dans la salle
petit n'en était rien et pas drôle qu'à
un moment donné c'est au fond de l'oeil
à pleurer pleurer les pierres des jeux
je dors ici ça se regarde et je
comprends beaucoup le fil qui la
pressent au bout de quelques mois menée
dans la psychiatrie normal mais la
picardie d'adultes et avait blessé sa
femme de 40 ans ils avaient dit comment
tu le dis mal mental est plein le fait
même que celle là dedans tout doucement
mais c'est probablement un épisode du à
toute la forte consommation de te le
super merde qui a pris l'eau durant les
derniers mois mais devant son enfant
dans cet étau en état de psychose le
n'importe qui peut devenir violent
agressif commettre des délits ou frapper
quelqu'un parce qu'ils voulaient ils
voient quelque chose d'autre comment les
drogues de synthèse est juste sur le
cerveau nous présentons au dr morin des
vidéos trouvées sur internet de
consommateurs sous l'emprise de ces
drogues
la police américaine a mise en ligne
l'arrestation de consommateurs 2ème des
pv une drogue chimique appelée sels de
bain
on voit qu une désinhibition très
important puisqu'il reid en face des
poteaux véhicules mus perdu la notion
des conventions sociales
[Musique]
donc le sait la paranoïa qui embarque la
méfiance la paranoïa y voit peut-être
des membres 37 hockey ce qu'ils veulent
mais de toutes les classes
personne n'en est en état d'arrestation
deuxième extrait nouvelle drogue
nouvelle hallucinations
ce qui est du son
c'est sûrement quelque chose sérieuse à
ce jeune homme a pris du k2 du cannabis
synthétique
est-ce qui voit son ami comme
parce que ce qu'ils voient que les mains
collées
peut-être qu'ils voient une grosse
talentueux ne sais pas de toute évidence
il voit tout comme son ami qui est même
pas capable de se lever c'est quand même
impressionnant parce qu'on pense que les
cannabinoïdes synthétiques peuvent
parfois être même plus puis ça que le
pire est potes
ce sont là un héroïnomane qui fait une
overdose on donne une arcade qui se
réveille pis si un antidote pour les
drogues de synthèse japonais au québec
impossible de savoir combien de
personnes ont été gravement intoxiquées
aux drogues de synthèse
ces données ne sont pas compilées aux
urgences et oui d'école décès dus à des
sandales de death note yves fentanyl on
voit aussi souvent des cas de décès dus
au ghb mélangé avec d'autres dépresseurs
du système nerveux central comme
l'alcool ou les benzodiazépines qui sont
des médicaments qui déprime la
respiration
donc on oui on envoie des causes de
décès malheureusement c'est pas toujours
répertorié comme on voudrait ml gobeil
est décédé l'an dernier à l'âge de 21
ans
dans un parti et elle aurait consommé un
cocktail de drogues de synthèse
le bureau du coroner enquête sur ce
décès qui pourrait être le premier lié
officiellement aux drogues de synthèse
au québec une sorte de la mine la
cocaïne mais consomme avec modération ce
partenaire alors les jeunes que nous
avons rencontrés ne sont pas conscients
des dangers
ils se disent en contrôle quand on
rentre sait pertinemment ce que tu
penses pas banaliser dans ce sens là
c'est les conséquences c'est toi qui
l'as
c'est moi chanteront peu mais je connais
des gens qui s'y connaissent mais moi je
pense c'est possible dans tron
raisonnements sont allés trop loin ça
c'est juste le bon milieu ça prend
souvent un incident tous les canaux un
organe qui fait une psychose plus dans
les autres sont témoins dessous
malheureusement ça prend souvent un
incident chez les filles par exemple
c'est une fille qui va se réveiller un
matin et puis que finalement et elle a
eu des relations avec 4,5 groupe est
assez pas trop commun puis presque un
black out comme avec caen sur tout cas
que de l'alcool de mélanger
malheureusement souvent savoir prendre
l'incident exemple l'alcool
des mélanges ensemble alcool et nba
[Musique]
l'appel d'accra sol de vue kbl grâce à
la bataille qui parle beaucoup
puis par le fouet j'ai réussi à contrer
[Musique]
mathieu meilleur bélisle est en
réhabilitation au centre dia nova
pendant huit ans il a consommé toutes
sortes de stupéfiants illégaux
mais c'est avec une substance légal au
canada qu'il a vécu sa pire expérience
une plante hallucinogène la salvia
divinorum c'est la pire chose que j'ai
fait vraiment c'est la paire drague gay
que je connais c'est le lait fait le
buzz que ça donne c'est comme une grosse
hallucinations j'en parle j'ai de la
misère cachée passagers je voyais plus
rien l'attendent à moins que tu étais
[Musique]
jamais mais jamais
avec qu'en vrai plainte est flatté
salle viala
c'est tellement fort là-dessus font des
hallucinations tellement folle j'ai vu
un gars sauter par la fenêtre de la
porte est devant moi
il parlait tout d'un coup il s'est mis à
crier tellement fort il ya sauté par la
fenêtre on était au troisième étage et
c'est grâce à jean il virer fou ça
sénégal mais j'imagine que oui et moi je
pensais qu'ils arrivent c'est légal
depuis longtemps mais salvia et c'est
l'hallucination naturel plus puis cinq
ans connaît sur la planète
la version synthétique mais au point par
des pseudos chimiste est encore plus
concentré ses effets d'autant plus
imprévisible
[Musique]
quinze ans encore au karément une
impression de décorporation ils ont
l'impression de se désintégrer
[Musique]
d'essai lancé par la fête comme vous
voyez garder l'eau aucune réaction est
encore dans son monde mais pourquoi ils
se lancent par la fenêtre mais
probablement parce qu'il se sent pas
bien imaginez vous que vous avez
l'impression de vous intégrer au divan
lequel vous avez prévu vous avez
disparaître dans 10 20 vous auriez
sûrement envie de vous sauver vous aussi
dans son rapport de 2013 l'office des
nations unies contre la drogue et le
crime se dit préoccupé par la
consommation de salvia particulièrement
chez les jeunes canadiens en 2011
ottawa promettait de classer la salvia
parmi les stupéfiants deux ans plus tard
ce n'est pas encore fait la salvia est
toujours légale
nous avons pu en acheter facilement des
boutiques spécialisées prétendent offrir
les substituts légaux aux drogues
nous sommes allés dans un de ses
magasins en caméra cachée
allo cherche quelque chose à milan ce
qui donne un beau jeu
[Musique]
la jeune vendeuse comprend tout de suite
ce que l'on cherche et les substances
qu'il nous propose sont censées limiter
les effets des drogues connues elles
sont vendues dans des sachets si du h
comme du haschich mais en synthétique
paraissait des plantes qui imite donc
fond la vendeuse semble bien connaître
sa marchandise et nous décrit les effets
du spice du cannabis synthétisée par des
chimistes et tout de suite je les ai eus
en fait c'est assez impressionnant sur
le crime et pendant une heure et demie
tfe riz et après une heure et demie
c'est fini déjà cet étonnant face à
mondeville
oui oui j'ai été assez impressionné je
pensais pas que ça rend tout oppose de
même où elle nous met en garde contre ce
produit plus puissant que le pote
organique qui vous rejoins ce niveau est
excellente
nous achetons deux sachets de cannabis
de synthèse elle veut nous rassurer nous
n'aurons pas de problèmes avec la loi
absolument la plupart du temps les
substances qui vont rentrer dans ces
commerces l'eau soit un désherbage des
pilules des comprimés dessous ça va
souvent les conditions seront interdits
dans plusieurs pays du monde
mais qu'ils sont pas rares au canada
mais ce n'est pas toujours vrai
la police de québec a trouvé il y a deux
ans des substances illégales et fait
fermer une de ses boutiques
quelques mois plus tard dans le local
voisin
une nouvelle boutique ouvrait avec les
mêmes produits novembre 2013
cette fois la police perquisitionne cinq
boutiques en même temps certains ce
temps ce qui était vendu ici
quant à royal admise à santé canada qui
ont été conclus en fait comme étant des
limites qu'analyste pris le dessus
c'est pour moi qui contrôle ce boulot
mais je voudrais en voiture pour
justement s'assurer l'accès les chansons
sont à la légalité qui contreviennent
pas aux catherinettes
[Musique]
mais pourquoi les gens et préfèrent
acheter sur internet c'est beaucoup plus
safe ya pas de risque qu'un god mettre
un gant d'en face puis qui prend ton
argent la plupart de mes clients c'est
des professionnels qui ont des familles
et des enfants
c'est exactement pour ça qu'il commande
par internet
parce qu'ils veulent pas aller dans rue
peel commandes et d'un pochon
probablement qu'ils connaissent même pas
de pochette alix fait toutes ces
opérations en ligne
il vend entre autres sur ce code c'est
en deux grandes où l'on vend des armes
des faux papiers et surtout de la drogue
on appelle ça le dingue net
tu as besoin d'un browser spéciale qui
s'appelle pour toutes les adresses sont
point oignons parce qu'il ya des couches
des couches et des couches de sécurité
s'ils essaient de meurtre assez ça va
aller ici
le site assure l'anonymat aux acheteurs
et aux vendeurs
il ya au moins deux sari sortie kamikaze
population à marcher en ce moment sur
ces 200 loges direct une douzaine
seulement qui sont illégales ricoh vient
chimiste qui m'a contacté il ya trouvé
une façon de changer la molécule de
cocaïne en substance qui ressemble à la
cocaïne mais qui pas détectable maxi la
police dpolg
ils peuvent pas te mettre en prison
parce que c'est légal enfin même pas de
nom encore juste un grand nom chimique
le que je peux même pas prononcé juste
l'an dernier les douanes ont répertorié
58 substances psychoactives des
substances non contrôlés qui sont entrés
au pays en toute légalité
c'est santé canada qui fait le tri et
décider lesquels seront classés parmi
les stupéfiants on a participé à une
enquête avec l'office des nations unies
contre la drogue et le crime et avant
d'annexer une substance faut être sûr de
certaines choses
faut être sûr que la substance en
question le produit chimique dont on
parle n'est pas utilisé des jeunes
également dans une autre sphère la
société eacom dans est ce que c'est une
drogue qui peut être utilisé au niveau
thérapeutique est ce que c'est une
drogue et utiliser le niveau industriel
longue et dure généralement 18 mois
entre temps la vente de ces produits est
interdite
une drogue de synthèse modifie les
fonctions organiques qu'un humain elles
ont tous ou la définition de drogue et
on peut saisir ces produits là sans
problème santé canada santé canada peut
intervenir ici mais pas les policiers
ils appliquent le code criminel et ils
ne peuvent rien faire tant que santé
canada ne classe pas ces substances
comme stupéfiant mais c'est sûr qu'il ya
des substances que ça peut être long
avant qu'il soit illégal fait qu'entre
août
si je prends l'exemple du baiser de paix
qui on a vu apparaître nous dès fin des
années 2000 2005 2006 2007
c'est plus qu'un avec ça devienne
illégal piquant qui ont intercepté des
ps dans l'opposition ce type de
comprimés nous explique stacy les gars
mais dans le fond ça va à peu près la
même effet à force législateur mon ami a
décidé de rendre illégal parce que c'est
pratique mais similaires
pendant qu'à ottawa on pèse le pour et
le contre à l'autre bout du monde
des chimistes produisent des drogues de
synthèse en quantité l'inde et la chaîne
sont les plus gros producteurs
la ferme avaler le quartier des
pharmaceutiques en banlieue de shanghai
un secteur hautement sécurisé
c'est ici que s'est installée eric dane
ce chimiste de travailler pour une
compagnie pharmaceutique avant de se
lancer dans l'industrie des huit search
que ma cause les nouvelles drogues de
synthèse
c'est à lui que nous avons commandé du
deux séries par internet
une équipe de la télévision française
l'a rencontré en caméra cachée dans ce
domaine on invente des nouvelles
molécules pour que nos produits soient
légaux c'est ce qu'on veut on veut la
légalité
[Musique]
ces laboratoires ultramodernes
ressemblent à ceux d'une compagnie
pharmaceutique ce narcotrafiquant
présente sa toute nouvelle drogue
hallucinogène un dérivé du lsd les gens
on découpe en morceaux et se le mettre
sur la langue
l'effet est proche du lsd un référé
secteur est resté le nouveau produit est
imprégné sur une feuille de papier et
camouflé par un dessin au choix du
client c'est lui lsd légal je les
fabriquer pour qu'il prenne la place du
lsd sur le marché on en vend de grosses
quantités en russie et aussi au
royaume-uni bio club nous l'apprenions
aussi sur du papier blanc
les gens le mettent dans leur sac et
quand ils arrivent à l'aéroport et que
les doigts me demande ce que c'est ils
répondent ce sont des documents chien ne
sentent rien non ils ne peuvent pas
s'est employé prépare une commande de 4
mg c'est cette substance est arrivée sur
le marché pour remplacer la méphédrone
quand elle est devenue illégale
la méphédrone aurait fait plusieurs
morts en angleterre
ça c'est du k 1 k 1
c'est sa nouvelle version du mx eu un
autre exemple d'une drogue qu'il a
modifié en changeant les molécules pour
en faire une drogue légale
le mx c'est vraiment du poison
mais ce produit c'est sans danger
ce n'est pas dangereux ce n'est pas des
poisons de nombreux qui ont essayé ce
produit selon différents dosages et
m'ont envoyé des rapports sur les effets
maintenant nous savons qu'il est sans
danger sur le marché chinois sur
différents marchés
le marché russe le marché chinois oui
sur différents marchés eric kingue
révèle une de c'est acté
vous pouvez faire comme d'autres ici
c'est écrit engrais pour les plantes
pour déjouer les contrôles douaniers
il écrit sur ces sachets qu'il s'agit
d'engrais ou dansant regardez impropre à
la consommation humaine
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi garder
hors de la portée des enfants
eric shine est fier de dire qu'il est un
gros joueur dans l'industrie on s'occupe
de toute la logistique
si le paquet perdu nous vous renverrons
gratuitement c'est notre garantie vous
faites mine d'argent expédié
gratuitement
oui bien sûr je me suis déjà fait 50
millions de dollars chaque jour ses 500
kg qui sort de mon usine
alors vous voyez on est vraiment pas des
petits en cas de problème je garantis de
nouveaux envois gratuit à tous mes
clients pas seulement en amérique en
europe partout il dit avoir des clients
au canada
nous vendons au canada nous en voyons
plus de 10 kg par semaine au canada
tout ce que je fais ici est légal la
police me connais je suis transparent
avec eux ils savent et je sais que tout
ce qu'on fait ici est légal je prenais
voici du mv 1
comment se battre contre des chimistes
comme eric trang capable de fabriquer
une nouvelle drogue
chaque mois chaque semaine ces
opérations sont légales enchaîné c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui choque la grc le
caporal luc chicoine s'est rendu à
shanghai l'été dernier pour convaincre
les autorités chinoises d'agir on n'a
pas de contrôle sur l'étranger faut pas
se conter une histoire des discussions
au niveau international sont en marche
pour essayer de changer les
réglementations mais c'est un pays à la
fois des démarches qui semble porter
fruit nous avons appris que les
autorités chinoises auraient eric schenk
dans leurs murs
le mois dernier le site mondial de vente
de drogue sur le code a été fermée dans
le fbi à mes appels quelques semaines
plus tard le site était de nouveau en
opération
l ex continue ses activités sur d'autres
sites moins surveillées stoppé pour une
journée de pêche à 3715 classe en tout
cas je peux dire que c'est plus cei par
la poste que dans un compte de banque
ont trois jours seulement notre commande
de drogue à eric trang est arrivé à nos
bureaux de radio canada de shanghai
notre colis a transité par même face aux
états unis avant d'arriver à montréal
[Musique]
interdit en europe de deux séries est
encore légal au canada
l'expéditeur a quand même pris soin de
le camoufler notre colis n'a pas été
intercepté
ni par les douaniers américains ni par
les douaniers canadiens
[Musique]